>> From the library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Steve Winick: Welcome,
it's September 12th, 2018.
We're here at the
Library of Congress.
My name is Steve Winick.
I'm the editor in the American
Folklife Center, and I'm here
with our guest John
McCutcheon, and John is going
to be performing
a concert tonight
in the Coolidge Auditorium,
and in the meantime,
we're going to ask him
some great questions
about his life and his career.
>> John McCutcheon:
Great, let's go.
>> Steve Winick: So, John,
let's begin with the sort
of typical question, your early
life and how you got interested
in all this music stuff?
>> John McCutcheon: Well,
I was born and raised
in Northern Wisconsin, a little
town called Wausau, Wisconsin
and was interested in music in
general the way young kids are,
but the seminal moment happened
actually not far from here.
I wasn't there, but my mother,
when I was 11 years old,
was watching television
in the middle of the day,
and my mother didn't
watch television, period.
And, here she was in
the middle of the day --
who know there was television
in the middle of the day,
and she said, "Come over
here and watch this with me."
And, I was the eldest of her
nine children, so I was the --
and my father was a traveling
salesman, so I was the closest
to adult companionship
that she had,
and what she was watching
was the March on Washington.
And, it was, as you probably
know, the first thing
in our nation's history
broadcast live on every channel,
which at that time meant three.
And, it was an astonishing
thing to watch, and the takeaway
of that for me, it was my
introduction to folk music.
I'd never heard of
folk music before,
and there was John Baos [assumed
spelling], Bob Dylan, and Peter,
Paul and Mary singing, what my
mother told me were folk songs.
And, I recognized them, because
they were all original songs
that they sang.
Well, there was Marian
Anderson and Mahalia Jackson,
which was a religious experience
for a kid from Wisconsin.
But, I recognized this music
as something that was deep
and potent, but also
something that was connected
to contemporary issues as well,
this being the most
contemporary issue.
It was on the news every night,
and my best friend was watching
at the same time, and we -- the
next day we saw one another.
I said, "Did you see that?
What was that," and we started
talking about this music
that we knew nothing about,
but that had really moved us.
And, we started listening to it.
It was at a time
-- this was 1963.
You could hear folk
music on the radio.
It was on television,
and it was --
I immediately went through
the sort of more rustic sound.
I mean, a few years
later I got a guitar,
because my best friend got
a guitar for his birthday,
and I went down to the library,
and the only book in the library
that could teach me guitar
chords was Woody Guthrie
folk songs.
And, I didn't know
who Woody Guthrie was.
I was 14, and I'd sung
a song from school.
Every American kid grows up
singing Woody Guthrie songs,
but they never tell you
who writes those songs.
So, I opened it up, and
here's a page of chord grids.
I thought, "Great, I
know what these are,"
and here's a whole
bunch of songs.
And, so my first real
heavy duty exposure
to learning this music was Woody
Guthrie, who was firmly planted
in traditional roots, built his
writing firmly on those roots,
and what it meant is I
completely missed the sort
of button-down collegiate
of folk music.
I didn't know for five
more years, for instance,
that the Kingston Trio existed.
I was right in the flannel
shirt and work boot world.
It was Woody and from there it
was [inaudible] and, you know,
somebody gave me
a Bob Dylan album,
and I could tell what
well he drank from.
So, it was, you know, it
began that crooked road
that took me right down
into one day saying,
"I want to play the banjo."
>> Steve Winick: Interesting.
So, one of the things
that you mentioned
that was interesting was
that these were all people
on TV doing folk music.
They were all doing, as
you said, original songs.
>> John McCutcheon:
Original stuff.
>> Steve Winick: So, that
sort of opens up that question
of the connection between
traditional folk music
and the original songs
that are called folk songs
by a lot of Americans.
What's your take on that?
>> John McCutcheon: Well, I was
-- I fell prey to that as well.
I mean, I knew that this
was somehow, you know,
when Pete Seeger sang John
Henry, Broadside, or --
and, then he sang, you know,
Who Killed Davey Moore.
They were somehow connected.
They were built on the same
matrix, and so I thought, "Well,
I'm going to write songs."
Look at this whole -- I finally
found out who Woody Guthrie was.
"These are all original songs.
I'm going to write
songs too," and I did,
and I wrote really awful songs
like you do when you start off.
And, they were all
the more awful,
because of the traditional songs
I knew that have been warm,
smooth, and beautiful
on thousands
of tongues before mine, and--
>> Steve Winick: So, they
were awful by comparison?
>> John McCutcheon: They
were awful by themselves.
My best friend, the
guitar guy who's --
we both started off
together, he's got a tape
of all those songs, and he
claims he's going to go right
up on YouTube if we ever
have a serious falling out.
So, you know, what I did when
I got to banjo world, you know,
I was going to a little
college in Northern Minnesota,
Saint John's University,
and it was at a time
when there were pretty
free willing
about giving people
independent studies.
And, I went to my adviser
and said, "I want to --
I'm going off the deep
end on this banjo thing,
and I can tell I'm heading for
not being in college anymore,
and is there a way we
can make this work?
Can I get credit?
I need to be around
banjo players."
And, Guy Carawan had
come to our college,
and I was designated his host,
because I was the only kid
in college who knew who he was.
And, then I met Pete
Seeger later on in the year,
and both of them said,
"You just got to go south.
If you want to play the
banjo, you got to go
down where it's part of
the meat and potatoes
of people's daily diet."
So, I convinced my adviser
to let me do a three-month
independent study of traveling
around the Appalachians.
I didn't have a car.
I was -- I hitchhiked, and
so there I was at the side
of the road with a
banjo and a backpack,
and it was like a free bus ride.
You know, people would
pick me up, and they'd say,
"You play that thing?"
And, I learned to say, "I
play at it," and they'd say,
"Well, play me something."
And, we'd be driving along
in a truck or something,
and I'd take it out and
play some and they'd say,
"You play that old-style."
And, people called it
alternately flailing
and whacking and knock down,
claw hammer, and old time.
And, they would say,
"Well, yeah,
that's like my Uncle Beechert
[assumed spelling] plays."
And, I'd say, "Well, where
does Uncle Beechert live?"
And, they'd say, "Well,
he's right up here."
And, I guess the prospect
of seeing two banjo
players was enough
to derail people's
plans for the day.
And, then it was, you
know, you meet one person,
and that one person would
say, "Hey, come on over.
We're going to have a party."
And, eventually, you know,
three month into this,
three-month independence study
I knew I was just figuring
out how to do this.
Because, you know, you come
out of academia, and you --
in a little room, and they -- a
professional teacher comes in,
armed with a pedagogy that
is sequential or whatever,
and to the exclusion of
everything else you study,
you know, late 18th
century French literature.
And, then you go
to another room,
and you do something entirely
focused and different.
With this, it was as about
as unacademic as possible.
They weren't teachers.
They didn't have
a pedagogy for me.
I just had to -- I had to learn
how to learn traditionally.
I had to learn how to listen
and remember and duplicate
and be quiet and pay attention
and hang around the fringes.
And, I discovered quite later
that I was the beneficiary
of a cultural phenomenon
that I didn't know --
I didn't recognize it in time.
I was part of the first
generation of kids who grew
up in that part of
the world who had --
was totally immersed into radio.
And, they were -- they had
all kinds of stuff coming in,
all kinds of music, and
the kids of the people
that I was just happening upon
in general were not interested
in learning that music.
They wanted to learn this
music, the popular stuff,
the stuff that would give
them, you know, possibilities.
And, there was the radio, there
were roads, there were jobs
in cities elsewhere,
and I end up knocking
on someone's door
unwittingly saying,
"I'm from a 1000 miles away, and
I'd like to learn this music."
So, I became the
unwitting beneficiary
of this cultural phenomena, and,
you know, it didn't take me long
to fall in love with everything
about the region, the people,
the music, the land, the stuff
that was just percolating
up in every -- you know,
whether it be the reform
of the mine workers union
or a popular protest
against strip mining.
What they call them [inaudible],
land rights issues, you know,
water issues, and every
little community seemed
to have this kind of stuff.
So, there was a lot of energy.
I thought I was going down to
learn how to play the banjo,
but what I found was the
most interesting thing,
and it's been my
study, since that time,
is how music functions in --
as a fundamental rather
than an ornamental part
of community life.
That's what was really
interesting to me.
And, if I learned some fiddle or
[inaudible] or a story or a song
or a dance or a hymn at
the same time, wonderful,
but if I walked away and just
got to go to a pie supper or go
to an old regular Baptist
meeting or whatever.
It was a treat.
>> Steve Winick: Great.
So, were you recording all
of this at the time or?
>> John McCutcheon: At first,
at the very first I wasn't,
and then as I started to
accumulate contacts and context,
I realized that I should
get some of this down.
I became friends with the people
at Appalshop in Whitesburg,
Kentucky, and they had good
recording equipment [inaudible]
boxes and stuff like that,
that I was able to --
and, I contacted
the Folklife Center.
Joe Hickerson was the head
archivist at the time,
and he and I have been
-- we're still friends.
I still see him every time I go
to Portland, but they arranged
to give me free reel-to-reel
tape,
and so I started off
doing it that way.
I got really dissatisfied
with reel-to-reel tape,
and I remember Mike Seeger and
I would have lots of discussions
about high-quality
cassette recordings,
just because it wasn't
-- it was less intrusive.
You could do more.
It could be longer, and I can't
tell you how many times I would
watch someone singing
or playing something,
and they're watching
the reels go around.
And, it just felt like it was
altering the whole atmosphere,
and I was all about, you know,
I was really reluctant to,
you know, it was sort
of like asking someone
if I could kiss their daughter.
Excuse me, I know
we've, you know,
I think I put my time in now.
One funny story.
One of the traditional
musicians that I was the closest
to was a fellow named Isaac
David Stamper, ID Stamper.
Just the most stunning mountain
[inaudible] player I've ever
met, of blues mountain
[inaudible] player,
originally from Searcy,
Arkansas, but his family moved
up to Letcher County, Kentucky,
and I met him at a festival,
and we agreed to
meet at his house.
So, I went to his house,
and after I was there
for about three hours, I
said, "Mr. Stamper, you know,
my memory is just not that good,
and I really love your music,
and would you mind if I went
out to my car and brought
in my tape recorder and
tape some of your stuff?
I'll be happy to make a copy
for you and your family."
And, he said, "I'm
so glad you asked.
Can I tape some of
your music as well?"
>> Steve Winick:
That's a nice outcome.
>> John McCutcheon: Yeah,
it's better than some
that's been around there.
I've heard lots of
stories over the years.
Somebody taped me,
and made a record,
and made a million dollars
off it, and there was no way
of dissuading people of that.
So, I was hesitant to do it.
A part of it was the
immediacy, but I also knew
that I was given incredible
intimate access to this stuff,
and for the longest
time I believed,
like a lot of people did and
some do, that this is dying out.
That wasn't my experience
at all, and it was vibrant
and evolving, and it's sort
of like, "Can I tape you?"
you know? You know, I didn't
meet people who wanted me
to be a human tape recorder,
mimicking what they played.
These were musicians.
They were interested
in being musicians.
They wanted to see,
well, how do you play?
You know, let's play
something together.
No, I don't care if you can
play just like me, you know,
and that's what I tried to do at
first, and I -- but I was young,
stupid, and I'd learned,
and now I'm old and stupid.
>> Steve Winick:
Well, your recordings
of ID Stamper are
here in the library.
There's copies of them,
and within that collection we
also have some other interesting
folks that you interacted with
and recorded at that time.
And, I wonder if you mind
telling us a little bit
about some of them, starting
with Peanut Cantrell.
>> John McCutcheon:
Peanut Cantrell was
from McMinnville, Tennessee.
He was one of the very few
hammer dulcimer players
in the south, and as a hammer
-- you know, when I got to --
when someone gave me a hammer
dulcimer it was -- she built it.
And, she said, "Here, I
just wanted to build it.
I don't want to play it.
You play a lot of instruments.
You could probably play this."
And, I started to, but I
felt really ungrounded,
because of all the instruments
I played, I had really sought
out people who'd
played all their lives.
I felt like they gave a
kind of, you know, gravity
and depth that I didn't find.
And, I couldn't afford to
take lessons, but when it came
to the hammer dulcimer,
I couldn't find anybody
who was a traditional player.
I went up to West Virginia
and met with Russell Fluharty
and Worley Gardner was up
in the Morgantown area.
And, I never made it up to meet
Chet Parker up in Michigan.
So, I happened to be out
at some fiddle convention
in McMinnville, and I decided
I was going to get up on stage
and play the hammer dulcimer.
And, somebody came
over to me and said,
"You know Peanut Cantrell?"
And, so I went over
to his house.
It was the only time we met.
He died shortly thereafter,
but it was so exciting for me,
because by this time I'd
actually been to Europe
and traveled around and found
hammer dulcimer type players
over there to find someone
with an American repertoire.
And, Peanut was a
perfect name for him,
little short guy and lovely man.
>> Steve Winick:
So, how did he play?
I mean--
>> John McCutcheon: It was
very simple type stuff.
I mean, I approached
the dulcimer as a drum,
because I got sticks in my
hand, and all of a sudden,
I was eight years old, you know,
beating on the table
with pencils.
So, I was -- you know, one
of the things I'm so grateful
for is that I went into
this whole experiment
with a completely open slate.
I didn't, you know, when I went
south, you know, I was raised
on the Beverly Hillbillies,
Little Abner, and Snuffy Smith,
and all that crap just
like everybody else.
But, luckily, somehow I
didn't believe any of it,
and everything was information.
So, with Peanut, it was --
I had no preconceptions of
what he was going to do.
It was just like, "Let's go.
Let's play," but it was --
you know, I have less --
I have fewer recordings of
him than I would've liked,
but I was really grateful that
I had an opportunity to see him.
>> Steve Winick: And, it's rare
that anyone recorded a
traditional hammer dulcimer
playing in the south anyway.
So, it's great that you did
get those recordings, yeah.
>> John McCutcheon:
Well, if you're --
I mean, that's one of the --
it's sort of like being
that 20-year-old kid
with the banjo and a backpack.
I had a signal out there.
This is what I do.
So, when someone saw me
play the hammer dulcimer --
I mean, the first time I
ever played the dulcimer,
I was at [inaudible]
Mountain Music
and Dance Festival in Asheville.
And, I was playing some
tunes, and I'd been playing
for 24 hours, but I knew how
to find fiddle tunes on it.
And, this woman said,
"I've never seen anybody
play the [inaudible] before."
So, it was a pretty
unusual instrument.
So, when I did, people
would come up and say,
you know about so and so.
>> Steve Winick: Right.
Great. Well, another person in
that collection is Cas Wallin,
who is kind of better
known I suppose,
but what was your
experience with [inaudible]?
>> John McCutcheon: I
stumbled into Sodom Laurel.
There are the three Laurels,
Shelton Laurel, Sodom Laurel,
and Big Laurel, up in Madison
County, North Carolina.
Many years ago, the Morris
Brothers from West Virginia,
John and David Morris, got a
grant from the Ford Foundation
to put on some community
festivals
around the Appalachian
south, and one of them was
in Sodom, and I heard about it.
I was probably 20-21 years
old, and I had heard some
of the Folkways Records of
people like Dillard Chandler,
and I -- so, I went up to this
festival, and it was, you know,
Sodom was properly named.
I mean, there was a
shooting, and a knifing,
and people would come around,
and say, "Stay in your tents."
But, the music was just
fantastic, and Cas, again,
was a short fellow,
very expressive,
and he would plant
himself when he would sing.
And, he would motion
with his arms, you know,
"Where will I shelter my
sheep tonight," and he had
that very adenoidal
kind of voice
and just an incredible
repertoire and a wicked sense
of humor, once you
got to know him.
And, his wife would talk the
entire time that he was singing,
which is memorialized
in the collection.
But, he sang old
ballads, and he was part
of that whole Dellie
Norton, Dillard Chandler,
Obrey Ramsey group up there
that -- and, Sheila Kay Adams,
by extension, who was Dellie
Norton's granddaughter,
and who I met that weekend.
We're -- Sheila Kay and
I are about the same age,
and we were both young, you
know, banjo struck young people,
who just wanted to eat, breathe,
and play traditional music.
And, I remember we sat
out most of that evening,
and then she took
me up to see Dellie,
who I think is the unsung star
of that whole clan up there.
I mean, her singing is just some
of my favorite in the world.
But, Cas -- I'm going
to be singing some
of Cas's stuff tonight, yeah.
>> Steve Winick:
Yeah, that's great.
Yeah, I think Sheila would
agree with you too about Dellie.
She talks about her.
So, one more person in
that collection is sort
of a separate tradition,
Michael Kennedy.
>> John McCutcheon:
I met Michael Kennedy
through my friend Malcolm
Delvish [assumed spelling],
who was a beautiful
hammer dulcimer player.
He was -- when I started
playing, I was living
in the Knoxville area,
and Malcolm was living
in the Cincinnati area.
And, because there weren't very
many hammer dulcimer players
in the world at that time,
we glommed on to one another
and just burned up I-75 going
back and forth between Knoxville
and Cincinnati, almost
every weekend if we could.
And, Malcolm was
particularly taken
with Irish traditional music,
and he met this fellow,
Michael J. Kennedy, who
was a melodeon player,
an Irish national immigrant to
this country, and he was living
in Covington, Kentucky,
which is right
across the Ohio River
from Cincinnati.
And, he would take -- and,
he and his musical partner,
Grey Larsen, would -- excuse
me, I just hit the mic.
He and his musical partner,
Grey Larsen, would take me
over to Michael Kennedy's
house, and I had, by that time,
started to organize some of my
field recordings into albums
for June Apple Records,
which was a, you know,
a nascent record company that
was a division of Apple Shop.
And, had gotten a small grant
from the National Endowment
for the Arts where Alan
Jabbour was the head of --
what was it called --
Folkarts or something like --
but, it was something even
more broad earlier on.
And, I'd gotten a small grant
to put some recordings together
and organize them into LPs,
and so I got together with --
at a radio station in
Cincinnati -- with Michael.
And, he wanted to
do it very formerly.
You probably, you know, people
who listened to it, you know,
he would announce what he was
going -- "This is this tune."
And, then he would play it,
and he wanted people to clap
at the end, which was
problematic, because after two
or three hours they
were sort of like.
And, I'm running
the tape recorder,
clapping like, "Come on guys.
Be a little more enthusiastic."
And, there's four of
us in the room, so.
But, he was a lovely man, and
he died -- when did he die?
But, I remember I
was passing through,
and he was in a hospice --
in a hospital, and I went --
Malcolm and I went by and played
him some tunes that would turn
out to be the night
before he died,
and Michael Malcolm called
me the next day to tell me,
and I thought, "I
hope that's my fate."
That some of my musical
friends will come in
and play something
at my bedside.
He was a beautiful man.
He looked -- you know,
it's funny I saw his picture the
other day, and I never asked him
if he actually got a
gig as Santa Claus,
but he certainly had that look.
>> Steve Winick: Excellent.
So, I mean, yeah,
it's interesting,
because you've mentioned
before that these traditions,
although we might have thought
at one point they were dying
out, they aren't really.
>> John McCutcheon: No, no.
>> Steve Winick: But,
the individual people
that you meet and record.
They pass on, and so--
>> John McCutcheon: As
we all do and will, yeah,
and so there was
a period of time
when I got much more aggressive.
Not aggressive, I
got much more --
spent a lot more time doing
field work and trying to figure
out how to do it
better all the time.
I mentioned that Mike Seeger
and I worked, you know,
there was a period of time
for years where we were both,
you know, really trying to --
we were experimenting
with different high-end
cassette recorders,
which seems like an oxymoron.
But, there were actually some --
Nakamichi had a three channel --
it was a stereo and a mono,
and I have some beautiful
recordings,
which I'll be sending
up to the library,
of this banjo players Will
Keyes [assumed spelling]
from Upper East Tennessee, from
Gray, Tennessee, and he played
in such a way -- he
lost one of his --
he lost the tip of his index
finger in a sawmill accident.
And, he, as a child -- so,
he learned to play the banjo
in this very unusual
two-finger style
where he could play all five
strings with his index finger,
because it was short relative
to what his thumb was.
And, he sort of held
the banjo out here.
So, the Nakamichi, for instance,
allowed me to do a stereo micing
and then put the third
mono mic actually in --
point it in the back of the
banjo, and it's the most --
it's my favorite banjo
recording I've ever heard,
because it's dull.
You're really inside the
banjo, and for someone
who plays it's sort of like
someone who plays the autoharp.
They get to hear this orchestral
sound, and to everybody
out in front it's sort
of [imitating strumming].
So, and then, of course, DAB
machines came and it's funny.
I remember I was in -- I
was thinking of this today,
knowing that we were
going to talk.
I happened to be coming
back from Nicaragua
where I had been doing a
bunch of field recording.
This is in 1980, mid-80s, and
I was waiting in baggage claim,
and up walks Flawn Williams,
an old friend of mine,
who at that time
was working at NPR.
And, he's saying, "So,
where have you been?"
So, I've just come back from
three weeks in Nicaragua.
I'm waiting for my
suitcases of tapes.
He said, "Yes, I just went
off for NPR to Vietnam,
and I've got a 100 hours."
And, I said, "I do too.
Mine is in three suitcases."
And, he said, "Mine is in the
shoe box under my arm here."
And, I said, "What?"
He says, "It's this
new technology,
a little tiny DAB machine."
So, of course, I
went out and got one,
and it changed everything.
It -- I mean, it was -- didn't
have the hiss of a cassette,
and again, it was even smaller
than the smallest
cassette machine.
And, it just made the
recording experience
for everybody much less
obvious, which is what you want.
>> Steve Winick: Right.
And, now, of course, the media
size is negligible compared even
to the equipment.
I mean, everything's
so small, yeah.
Yeah.
>> John McCutcheon: Yeah, and --
but, back then, it
was the Wild West.
I'm really grateful
that I had access
and [inaudible] studios
here in the area.
Bill McCaroy [assumed
spelling] had a Nagra
that I would rent
from time to time.
So, I mean, I was
grateful I had access,
because there was a period
of time I had a wallet sack.
>> Steve Winick: Right.
>> John McCutcheon: You
know, big bear of a thing,
and it was like you
were moving a television
into somebody's house.
>> Steve Winick: And, the funny
thing is they called those
things portable, because
they had handles on them.
>> John McCutcheon: Yes.
>> Steve Winick: But, yeah.
>> John McCutcheon: Well, you
know, it's sort of like what's,
you know, the original
laptop computers where--
>> Steve Winick: Right.
>> John McCutcheon:
Filled your whole lap.
>> Steve Winick: Yeah.
Yeah, great.
So, well we've talked
about a couple
of the instruments you play,
but the hammer dulcimer kind
of stands out being
an unusual instrument,
but also people consider you
a master of this instrument.
So, you talked about your
beginnings with the instrument,
but how did you get
further involved?
>> John McCutcheon:
I had a girlfriend
who took an instrument
building class
up in [inaudible] West Virginia,
and I went up to visit her
at the end of this class,
and she had built this thing
called a hammer dulcimer.
I'd heard about it.
I'd seen Guy Carawan play
it and that was the --
you know, I never thought
I wanted to play it.
But, she said, "Here, I have
this thing that I've built,
and I just -- I've
accomplished my goal.
Why don't you," -- and,
my birthday was nearby,
and she said, "Here,
happy birthday."
>> Steve Winick: That was
nice, and what was her name?
>> John McCutcheon: Jude
Odell [assumed spellings],
and she is a wonderful banjo
player who lives up in --
and jeweler who lives
up in Indianapolis.
And, it's, you know, there
are many different tunings,
but the tuning that has
sort of become dominant
in American music
now is very logical,
and it was diatonically set up,
and I was primarily a
fiddle player at that time.
It happens, you know, banjo
players discover the fiddle,
and then they are -- they fall
into the rabbit hole
of the haired bow.
And, so I was just
playing fiddle.
So, I had an encyclopedia
of fiddle themes in my head,
and I just started
pecking them out, and,
"Okay I know how this
works," plus you can do rolls,
and when I was a kid, I
wanted to play the drums.
And, so this was like the
close -- it was a string drum,
and so what I did, as far
developing my playing on it,
I mostly played fiddle
tunes, but I was different
from most other hammered
dulcimer players
that I was meeting.
And, they included people like
Sam Rizzetta and Paul Reisler
who played with Sam in the
group Trapezoid and Malcolm.
Different people who were
all parts of ensembles.
They had some kind of
chordal foundation upon
which they were playing, and
it effected how they plaid.
I was a soloist.
I wasn't going to be in a band.
I didn't want to be in a band.
It was nice and mobile and
portable, and it worked for me.
So, I had to figure out
how to create some kind
of harmonic foundation upon
which to play, and it really --
so, I was playing these
tunes, and then trying
to create an accompaniment
at the same time
or at least an arrangement that
didn't make people say, "Well,
that'd be pretty good if
he had a guitar player
with him or something."
But, I was also looking for
those traditional players,
and I was frustrated
enough that I knew
of a fellow named
David Kettlewell
who had done a book called, "All
the Tunes That Ever There Were,"
which was a little
mimeographed thing I got
from Andy Spence
[assumed spelling].
Talked about a bunch of dulcimer
players throughout England
and Ireland.
So, I said, "I have the same
feeling as when I open that,
you know, Mountain Music of
East Kentucky album that came
into our college library."
There was a picture of
Roscoe Holcomb on the front,
and inside was directions.
You know, here's where
these people live,
and I thought, "Okay, I'm going.
I want to have some kind
of traditional foundation
for my playing."
So, I went over and met
Bill Fell [assumed spelling]
and Billy Bennington, and the
absolute star was Jimmy Cooper.
Just the most astonishingly
versatile player.
He played on streets
as a young man
and just played all
the kinds of tunes
that you would expect a
traditional Scottish player
to play.
[Inaudible] and [inaudible] and
hornpipes and jigs and reels,
but he also played Cha
Chas and old parlor songs
and accompanied singing,
and it was like opening
up a whole world, because prior
to that it had been
fiddle tunes.
Then, I started with
ragtime piano pieces.
>> Steve Winick: There's
a certain logic to that.
>> John McCutcheon: Yes,
and then in the mid-70s,
I discovered [inaudible]
Caroline, and said, "Okay, well,
I'm going to take harp music,"
which, again, there's a kind
of logic to this,
but I came back,
and this is 1977,
when I met Jimmy.
I came back, and I was playing
at the Buffalo Folk Festival,
and my -- I didn't know my
life was about to change.
I was doing a hammered
dulcimer workshop,
and this young woman came up
to me and said, "You know,
my dad plays the dulcimer."
I said, "Really?"
She says, "Yeah, my dad
and his two brothers
and my great-grandfather
and, yeah,
so it's a tradition
in our family."
And, I said, "I would
love to meet your father."
And, she said, "I bet
he'd like to meet you."
And, so the day after
the festival I went
over to her house, and
there sat Paul [inaudible],
and he changed everything.
I mean, not only did he
become one of my dear friends,
but he was a guy who was the
most musical dulcimer player
I've ever met.
He loved to play.
In fact, I walked
in, and there he was,
sitting behind his dulcimer
with his hammers in his hand,
you know, like, "Come on.
I don't want to know
about your family.
I don't want to make small talk.
Let's just play."
And, he made everything he
played sound like it was written
for the dulcimer, and it
was like a light going off,
and I thought, "This is what
American hammer dulcimer
music is."
And, he just passed
away in March.
>> Stephen Winick: March, yeah.
>> John McCutcheon: And, he --
at 97, and at 97 he was still
the best hammer dulcimer I've
ever heard.
He'd -- and, he got more
adventurous the older he got.
When I met him, he
was playing a dulcimer
that his grandfather had
built, and it was a fifth
across the treble bridge,
and then like the
Michigan players an octave
from the right-hand side
of the treble bridge
to the bass bridge.
And, it was a really
funky instrument.
And, it was held together with
bailing wire and scotch tape,
and he was very interested
in my Rizzetta instrument,
because it was chromatic, and
eventually had dampers on it,
and it was light, and
it stayed in tune well,
and so he ordered a
Rizzetta instrument.
And, Sam tweaked
it here and there
to make it even more chromatic,
and then he was off
to the races.
Whenever you saw
Paul after that,
he was playing the
most wild chromatic --
you know, let's substitute
this B flat chord here
for this, you know.
And, so he was really
adventurous, loved music,
loved musicians,
and he was just --
I don't know what my
playing would have been like,
and he was learning new tunes.
>> Stephen Winick: Was
he trained as a musician?
I mean, like reading
music and all that?
>> John McCutcheon:
No, not at all.
He learned to play from
his maternal grandfather,
a fellow by the name of Jesse
Martin [assumed spelling],
who was a professional
hammer dulcimer player.
He played in movie houses.
>> Stephen Winick: In
that Henry Ford era when--
>> John McCutcheon:
He won the audition
to be Henry Ford's hammer
dulcimer player, but he --
but, Henry Ford, very
famously, was a [inaudible],
and Jesse Martin, very
famously, was not.
So, he won the audition,
but never played, but --
so when he -- he
played in movie houses,
while they were changing
the reels, and, you know,
and people who know
what I'm talking
about are officially old.
And, then in his retirement
he moved in with his daughter
and taught his grandsons,
Phil, Paul,
and Sterl [assumed spelling],
and Sterl was a fixture and sort
of the -- he played fiddle
and dulcimer in the sort
of western New York Bluegrass
and folk music world.
Phil, who built dulcimers,
moved to Arkansas,
and I actually have one
of his dulcimers built
after his grandfather's design,
and Paul lived in [inaudible].
Paul was a tool grinder for
[inaudible] craft by trade,
and then when he -- it's funny.
I was just playing at the Wheat
Lands Music Festival up at --
near Traverse City,
Michigan this last weekend.
And, some people came up to
me, while I was there, saying,
"I remember when Paul
[inaudible], and you would come
to the Everett, you
know, old time music
at the hammer dulcimer
convention,
and Paul would be the first one
up and the last one to bed."
He would wear everybody
out in the jam sessions,
and I attended several
[inaudible] family reunions
where I got to hear the
three brothers play together
which was just angelic.
>> Stephen Winick: Amazing.
>> John McCutcheon: Yeah.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
So, in addition to playing all
these instruments you're also a
well-known songwriter, and I
wanted to ask you about writing
for different instruments.
I mean, do you write a song
for a particular instrument
or what's your writing
process like?
>> John McCutcheon: I tend to --
the two instruments I
write the most for --
on are guitar and piano,
and I switch back and forth,
and sometimes, in the middle
of writing of something
when I'll just say, you
know, "I want to have," --
the guitar for me
is very blockish,
the way it's all set up, and
the piano is very linear.
And, it's all about voice.
But, everyone now and again, you
know, I'll be writing something,
and I'll say, "This
is a banjo piece."
And, to me all these instruments
are absolutely related.
I mean, number one I started
playing all these instruments,
because I would be at
some banjo player's house,
and a fiddle player
would be there,
and we would have
the same vocabulary.
And, I remember the first time
I ever played a fiddle I was
at a square dance in
Benfield, Tennessee,
and the fiddle player
didn't show up.
And, I was used to
playing the banjo,
and somebody there had a fiddle,
said, "Here, you can play this."
And, I said, "No, I can't."
They said, "Well, the
dance is 20 minutes long.
You know what the notes are.
By the end of this 20 minutes
I'll bet you'll be playing it."
And, they were right.
I could play really badly
this particular tune
by the end of it.
So, it was -- and, so
then you realize, well,
this is the same
fingering as the mandolin,
and a lot of it was
just you're using --
you're doing this with one hand
and something completely
unrelated with the other.
So, once you get this
tapping your head
and rubbing your belly.
All that is to say that I look
at these as having a great, big,
really expensive tool box, and
when I'm writing something,
sometimes I will write it on the
guitar and I'll say, "No, no,
it doesn't belong there."
Or, what would it be like?
How would this change?
And, sometimes it's
an atmospheric thing.
A banjo gives it a different --
Wade Ward, one of my
favorite musicians from down
in Independence, Virginia had
this beautiful way of talking
about musical terminology,
and he would call --
when you wanted to play
in the key of A, he'd say,
"Let's get up in that
high atmosphere."
And, I always thought that's
such a beautiful way of talking
about keys and the different
voices of, you know --
whether I'm writing
in a voice, you know,
I'm going to be a 14-year-old
Native American girl,
or whether I'm going
to say I'm going
to give this piece an atmosphere
by singing it with the fiddle.
You know, it -- sometimes,
it happens right
from the beginning, and
sometimes it's saying, well,
let's try on another
suit of clothes
and see what it looks like.
>> Stephen Winick: So,
in your song writing --
I mean, you've mentioned
Woody Guthrie
and Pete Seeger as
two influences.
Are they influences
on the songwriting part
of your life as well?
>> John McCutcheon:
Woody, certainly,
because in that book
-- this was a book
that I thought was a
guitar instruction book.
I mean, that's how little
I knew about Woody Guthrie,
and it as was a -- and,
so I thought, "Well,
it's an instruction book, so
you start in the beginning."
And, I went sequentially,
and it took me an embarrassingly
long time to realize
that it was arranged
alphabetically.
I mean, what are the chances
that all the easier songs start
with A, but what that meant,
that kind of, you know,
that's just how they
decided to do it.
One page was a love song,
the next was a kid song,
and then there'd be
an historical song,
and then a topical song,
and then a funny song
and an angry song.
And, it was an introduction
to someone who wrote
about everything for
every possible audience.
It wasn't weird to write
kid songs directed to kids.
It wasn't weird to write a
song about a historical event
that you knew your
listener knew nothing about.
Your job was to pay attention
and to try to tell the truth.
And, so that was huge.
I mean, that was -- and to
have guts, to be courageous,
to be willing to name things,
and to give something of --
I mean, I remember one
of the very first --
because, it was alphabetical,
one of the very first songs
in this book was
the 1913 Massacre.
And, I got to this line
that said, "I'll take you
through a door and
up a tall stair."
And, man, I was there.
It was very, you know,
a song as a movie,
and I thought that's
how I want to write.
I want to be that cinematic and
take people inside, you know,
invite them into these spaces.
So, yeah, Woody --
the songwriters that were
really powerful for me,
as I was starting out,
was Jean Ritchie who is
such a good songwriter that
most people don't know she's
a songwriter.
>> Stephen Winick: Right,
they don't know the
songs were hers, right?
>> John McCutcheon: Yes, and
you hear a song like Cool
of the Day, and you --
which, she told me once that
she wrote while she was ironing.
And, most people don't know that
that's not a traditional song.
Hazel Dickens, the same thing.
I mean, she was thoroughly
immersed in traditional music,
and so her writing
came out of that,
and talk about a courageous
writer, that song Black Lung.
My god. Utah Phillips, again,
came out of that school
of knowing, you know,
about traditional music,
using those forms, and
having a kind of empathy
and compassion that, you know --
I mean, to Utah no
one was dispensable.
And, so yeah, you'd --
funny thing, why is he singing
me this song about this hobo?
I don't know anything --
I don't know any hobos.
Are there hobos anymore?
And, all of a sudden,
you couldn't look away,
and that was the kind of writing
that really inspired,
and continues.
Bernice Reagon Johnson, just
an astonishing songwriter that,
again, people don't know.
And, she came right
out of the church.
>> Stephen Winick:
Yeah, absolutely.
Yeah, and that's
another kind of influence
that you can detect
in your songs.
I guess, there's both kind of
the sacred heart side of things
and the African-American
spiritual side, so.
>> John McCutcheon: Well, I, you
know, I grew up as a Catholic,
which has the meagerest
singing tradition.
I was actually the seminary
for a couple of years,
and when I decided I was going
to leave, I told my mother.
I said, "No, I don't think
I want to be a priest.
I think I'd rather
be the choir leader."
And, she said, "That's a tougher
job at a Catholic church."
So, when I came to a
place that was, you know,
there was this rich
musical tradition.
And, it was -- I could be
completely misspeaking,
but I think American folk music
is unique or certainly rare
in that it includes
religious music
in music that's considered
folk music.
And, you know, on one
hand I would be sitting
with Janette Carter, and
she would be singing,
"Little Moses," or "The
Poor Orphan Child,"
and the next day I would be
attending a regular Baptist
service with Roscoe Holcomb.
And, everybody somehow knows
the melody of this circuitous --
and, someone is lining
out the words,
and then the next day I would
be at an old harp singing,
and it was all religious music,
completely different stuff.
And, the next night
I'd see Ralph Stanley
And The Clinch Mountain
Boys doing, "Oh, Death," or,
"Children Go Where I Send Thee,"
or "Cry From The Cross," or,
you know, "Two Coats
Lay Before Me."
And, it was -- again, I think
if you look at the history
of political music
in this country,
the most powerful
stuff was the music
from the Civil Rights Movement.
And, a lot of it was
because it had the depth
of not only it being
traditional based,
but spiritually based
stuff, which gave it a kind
of gravitas that, you know,
newly composed stuff
just wasn't approaching.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
Well, the other sort of great
political movement bringing us
songs was the Labor Movement,
and I know you've worked
with both, labor songwriters
and labor as a musician.
So, let's talk just a little
bit about your projects
with [inaudible], for example.
>> John McCutcheon: Well,
Sai [assumed spelling],
as the people who are watching
this, is a rabbi's son who grew
up in State College,
Pennsylvania and signed
up for SNCC in the
very early days
of the Civil Rights Movement.
He, you know, was a
guy who played guitar,
but wasn't writing songs, but
quickly understood the kind
of plane spoken vernacular
usage of people's own words.
I mean, when you -- when one
of the things that I recognize
about Sai's music early on,
this is back in the days
where he denied he was writing,
and he would flat-out lie.
"No, I didn't," you know?
I'd be at a party [inaudible],
"Wow, that was a great song.
Where did that come from??
He says, "This guy down
the road," and eventually,
I just drove down to his house
in Mineral Bluff, Georgia,
and I said, "I want to meet
this guy down the road."
And, he says, "Well,
I wrote it."
And, I said, "Well, why
aren't you admitting this?"
"Well, because everyone
is into collecting stuff.
Now, and I figured
if I said I wrote it,
the people wouldn't
take it seriously,"
sort of like J.P. Fraley, who
I spent a lot of time with,
and he wrote half the tunes
he played, but he said --
and he would confide in you.
I mean, he's dead now, so I can
-- he'd confide, and he'd say,
"Well, if I told so
and so I wrote that,
they wouldn't pay any attention
to it, so I tell them that I,
you know, collected
it from [inaudible],
or I learned it from
my grandfather."
But, Sai is just one
of the most prolific
and wonderful songwriters
in his spare time.
We met on a Harlan County picket
line on Thanksgiving Day, 1972.
He was there working with
the Brookside Strike,
the subject of Harlan
County, USA,
the Barbara Kopple
Academy-award-winning film,
and I was there, because I
didn't have a Thanksgiving
Day invitation.
And, I knew there was a strike,
and I figured, okay, well,
I'll go up and sing
at the picket line.
So, I was sitting around a 55
gallon oil drum with a bunch
of guys who were wanting to be
back at work, and somebody said,
"There's a guy who is a banjo
player down at the picket line."
And, so I showed up.
And, he was working for
the UMW at the time,
and we recognized our mutual
love of traditional music
and southern music and struck
up a partnership that exists
to this day, and we started
writing songs together
in the early 1990s.
We did a lot of work together,
and we toured together
in the early and mid-80s,
but we were both singing
our own songs at that point.
We started writing
together, because we're guys,
and we had to have an
excuse to get together.
We'd have to say well, you know,
"Yeah, we just like to hang
out for a few days, but
that would be weird,
and we don't hunt.
So, why don't we get
together and write songs?"
And, we found that we
worked really well together,
because we were compatible
and complementary.
Sai is a wall and stud guy,
and I'm the guy who comes in
and does the finish work,
and the way we would write is
sometimes I would write a whole
song, sometimes he would
write a whole song.
We used the Lennon and McCartney
rule, everything that, you know,
everybody knows John Lennon had
nothing to do with, "Yesterday,"
but they both -- you know,
this is an agreement.
But, there were times
when we would --
Said would come up with some
structure, and he'd say,
"Fine, okay, you finish it."
And, years later he
would see it on an album,
and it would be credited to him.
He said, "Did I have
anything to do with it?"
Yeah, yeah, you did, and at the
time I started working with Sai,
I was the kind of guy that if
I wrote a song, I was like,
"That's a good day's work."
And, Sai would say,
"Great, what's next?"
And, we got to the point
where we wrote an entire album
in a day and a half,
and it was a good album.
We got a Grammy nomination
for it, but we were just
in the groove, and
we were, you know,
passing stuff off
back and forth.
And, Sai would go off and take
a nap, which he's really good at
and come back and
be ready to go.
He's the most present
person I've ever met.
He's just, you know, I got
to do a conference call,
and he's right there,
and then he hangs up
and he's right back there.
He's astonishing, and
he's also an endless font
of fantastic ideas.
I just recently started
doing his song that --
I remember when he
wrote it called,
"Go To Work On Monday
One More Time."
It was just -- he was working
on the J.P. Stevens Boycott
at the time, and
he happened to --
they were trying to get
brown lung introduced --
recognized as an
occupational disease.
And, he just -- it was
a guy talking about,
you know, "I'm sick.
The doctor is lying to me,
my boss is lying to me,
and everybody knows
what's wrong,
and I can't do anything else.
So, I'm just going
to have to go to work
on Monday one more time."
And, it's, you know, I've
known that song for 40 years,
and every time I sing it, and I
just -- I do it with fiddle now,
just give it a different voice.
It's an astonishing song, and
it's so effecting, and it's one
of the things that fiction does.
It opens us op to an
experience that we would --
I mean, I defy anybody
not to be changed somehow
by hearing this really authentic
voice saying, you know,
"The doctor says
I smoked too much.
He says that I ain't trying.
He says he don't
know what I got,
but we both know he's lying.
I'm going to work on Monday
one more time," and not just be
in that guy's presence.
And, it's a special
songwriter that can do that,
and Sai is that kind of
songwriter, and I'm lucky enough
to sort of be on the planet
at the same time he is,
and we're pals, and we
get to write together.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
Well, there's one other pal
I'd like to ask you about,
because I had the pleasure
of interviewing her here
when she was here, and
that is Carmen Aberdeen.
>> John McCutcheon: I
mean, I do know her.
>> Stephen Winick:
Carmen is John's wife.
>> John McCutcheon: Yes,
yes, for ten years now.
Well--
>> Stephen Winick: I mean,
as an influence though.
>> John McCutcheon: It was
her birthday yesterday.
You know, I met Carmen sort
of back in the mid-90s.
I was doing a collection for --
I was on the board of
Grassroots Leadership
which was Sai's regional
organizing organization.
That was his real job.
He was a great songwriter in
his spare time, and I was --
I put together a multicultural
children's album of music
for the, you know, for
1992, the 500th anniversary
of Columbus stumbling
on the New World.
And, it was very successful,
and I didn't know Carmen at all,
and I was going to do a
multicultural storytelling album
to benefit the same
organization,
and our mutual friend Michael
Parent [assumed spelling],
who was a wonderful storyteller
of French-Canadian descent,
said, "Well, here's
who you should get."
And, I had been to the National
Storytelling Festival a couple
of times, I guess as sonic
relief, but somebody recognized
that a lot of John's songs tell
stories or have introductions
that are more than
just sort of pedantic
or I wrote this because.
And, Carmen was one of
the people I approached,
and she agreed to
be a part of this.
And, then once it was clear
that she and I were an item,
I got invited almost every year
to the National Storytelling
Festival, and that was
where I was really in the
company of workers of the word.
And, if you're a
word nerd like I am,
just to hear people
use language,
it was one of the things
that made me fall in love
with the south, just the
way people would talk.
I mean, I had, you know, and
people would say, you know,
"I just dread Christmas,
all this rushing and
swarping around."
Or Janette Carter
used to say, "Well,
that Johnny Cash just needs to
get all his shit in one sock."
And, I just thought, well,
that's a weird thing,
but I know what you
mean, you know.
Or, she was in a
state of high fuss.
And, my exposure
to the storytelling world via
my relationship with Carmen --
but, I mean, Carmen has
the best sense of story
of anyone I know,
in her writing.
She's the hardest-working
writer I know.
I mean, she has primarily
worked in the world
of children's picture books,
which everybody looks at
and says, "This is 32 pages.
How hard can that be?"
But, she completely
understands the form.
She's working on a
book until they tear it
from her fingers to print it.
I mean, she gets [inaudible]
fold it and gather the proofs
and says, "I want to --
no, I got to change
that line right there."
She just wants to
make it perfect.
She is the hardest-working
writer I've been around,
but a great sense
of story in both,
the way she tells her
stories and that sense
of story has really
influenced my songwriting.
I mean, my last album of
original songs, I look at it,
and I thought I couldn't have
written that ten years ago.
I didn't know how to use --
I mean, I understand the
distillation of language
that songwriting and poetry is,
but to present a convincing
story and not have that pebble
in the shoe moment was
something that, you know --
I did an album of songs and
stories that I recorded live
at the National Storytelling
Festival.
And, one reviewer happened
to say, "It's obvious
that his marriage to Carmen
Aberdeen has turned him
into a first rate
storyteller," so.
>> Stephen Winick: Even
better storyteller.
>> John McCutcheon: Well, and
I showed that to her, and she,
of course, said, "No,
you were great before."
But, it's true.
It's true.
You can't -- if you are someone
who loves words and loves story
and loves the world that you
can create in a few minutes,
you can't help, but
be influenced by her.
I would like to think
she is influenced by me,
but I certainly know that
I'm influenced by her.
>> Stephen Winick: All right.
Well, I think we have
to leave it there,
but it was wonderful
to have you here.
John McCutcheon,
thank you so much.
>> John McCutcheon: Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov